a birthday president for President Trump
on Friday after the Justice Department
released a legal opinion saying that
Treasury secretary Steve minutiae was
right to withhold president Trump's tax
returns from a House committee that
subpoena them Nikole Killion is at the
White House with more Nicole good
morning good morning to you Dana and
this appears to be a victory for
President Trump at least for now you'll
recall back in May the House Ways and
Means Committee issued a subpoena for
six years worth of the president's tax
returns at the time Treasury secretary
is Steve minuchin refused to turn over
the documents saying the request lacked
a quote legitimate legislative purpose
in its decision Friday the Justice
Department backed that up
the 33 page opinion said because the
committee's chairman congressman Richard
Neal wanted to make the president's tax
returns public the requests didn't meet
criteria for a legitimate legislative
function the battle for president
Trump's tax returns has been going on
since before he was elected in 2016 the
partisan battle got new life in 2018
when Democrats took back the majority in
the House
this decision is likely to fan the
flames between congressional Democrats
and Attorney General William Barton's
Bay accused of trying to stonewall
Congress Oregon Senator Ron Wyden said
the opinion further reflects Attorney
General bars willingness to protect the
president at all cost besides mr. Trump
every president since Richard Nixon has
made his tax returns public Anthony
Nicole thank you